- You didn't tell me
this was gonna be some
Chris Angel David Blaine Bullshit.
- My name is Gary Ferrar.
I am a magician and a
mentalist in New York City.
I have snuck into the Buzzfeed offices
pretending to be a Psych student
who is administering tests
to some of the staff.
My name is Gary.
- Okay, Gary.
- I'm a psych student.
We're gonna work on a little evaluation.
Where we basically evaluate
people's perceptions
and observation skills drunk.
We're gonna give them some drinks
and see if they can still observe as well.
- So we're getting drunk, taking tests
and seeing if we pass or
fail those tests betterer?
- I function better on alcohol.
- Okay, you guys are gonna
drink for a little bit.
We'll come back, we'll see how you do.
What they don't know, is that
I'm gonna be sneaking in magic.
You guys ready to get drunk?
- Let's drink.
(hard energetic music)
- I think they are obviously well enough
intoxicated at this point.
- I feel like I'm making like
the ugly drunk face right now.
- If you can catch your breath.
- Gary, we're little people.
- I'm sorry, doctor.
- Little people drink really quickly.
- Can I call you doctor though?
- Doctor Gary.
- No, I'm not a doctor.
- Can I call me doctor?
- Let's go it?
Oh man.
- So the first thing we're gonna
do is just like a reflex test.
I'm gonna ask you a question.
Don't respond.
Keep your mouth open so
like if you had the impulse,
your lips would move,
but don't actually do it.
And then the idea is
like as you get drunker,
sometimes you can't control
that impulse to stop.
What is your wife's name?
I can feel myself.
I didn't even want to
say it but like my mind
was like do something.
- Cause I got like a,
it was like a B like Br.
- What?
Yes!
- Bridg, Bridg?
What is it, Bridget?
- Bridget!
- Bridget, yeah, okay.
- What?
- Let's move on to test two.
How much money would you say is there?
- [Girls] One, two.
(speaks foreign language)
- How much value is that?
That's the real question.
- It's a Starbucks latte.
- [Men] Five dollars.
- Wait, that's a $100 bill.
- Wait, are you kidding me?
- Yeah, you didn't notice.
It's one--
- Oh my god.
You were just counting them.
You didn't notice that they were hundreds?
- No, I didn't know this.
- You didn't have $100 bill,
I would have taken that.
- That's bullshit.
- Actually look, that one's
a $100, that one's a $100.
- Dude I got my wallet upstairs.
I got 10 bucks can you
turn it into a thousand?
- That's $100.
That is some strong vodka.
- Oh this is a trap.
- This is a trap.
- This guy's a fucking magician over here.
- You know what?
- Do I get to keep the 100?
- No wait, I am a magician.
- Are you actually?
- That's actually what I do.
- She brought in a fucking magician.
- Guys, this is the best day of my life.
- You're going to college
to learn magic tricks?
- Oh this is so cool.
- I believed you.
You had glasses on and everything.
- And now I don't have to
pretend to be a psychologist.
We're gonna get to the real magic.
- If I bring this one up on this side
and this one up on this side.
There's not free, this is
actually just one long string.
- What the hell?
- Where did it go?
- This is solid, yes?
- It is.
- We line up the ends,
pull down on the middle.
- Okay.
- Put your hand on there.
- Get out of here with your witchcraft.
- Believe that they're two.
- Two, I believe, I believe, I believe.
- I believed hard enough, dude.
Peter pan is with me.
- They are confusing us.
- What?
My new hobby is gonna be getting drunk
and going to magic shows.
- I'm gonna draw an x right here, yeah?
Do you know how you get rid of sharpie?
You need like rubbing
alcohol or something.
You guys might just be
able to sweat it out.
But if I squeeze tight.
- This mother fucker.
- Watch watch, don't move, squeeze tight.
- Oh my God, you're kidding me.
- I drew in my hand with sharpie, right?
- Okay, please reveal.
- Okay take a look.
In my hand it's like the x was not there.
Chris, take a look in your hand.
That was here.
- Oh what the?
- The real story is you
passed out from drinking.
(screaming)
- When did you do this?
When did you put this here?
- You sorcerer!
- Thank you.
You guys have been real.
- Oh thank you doctor.
- You guys happy?
The internet will be happy?
- Chris is agitated.
- Couple shots deep and I
look like a big old goof.
- Hell yeah I believe in magic.
- Harry Potter was in the room with us.
- Is that Harry?
- Harry!
- He's got the glasses.
- I think that's Harry.
- Magic is fucking real.
- It's so cool.
- Believe in magic
because if Gary the doctor
can put an x on my hand
which is still there.
- That's nuts.
He can put have put one on your balls
and you don't know that yet.
That's crazy.
- [Man] Didn't say it.
- But I did.
- [Man] Let me check.